hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com today we're
continuing our coverage of the
2020 us chess championships we are in
round number seven the start of day
number three so i've had first two days
they play three rounds
every single day today is the exact same
so playing around seven
eight and nine our competitors white's
gonna be played by jeffrey xiong we did
watch him
get a victory on day number one and his
opponent
playing the black pieces is nakamura
nakamura is the defending
champion of this tournament and
in last year's tournament he actually
beat jeffers young he needed to beat him
in the final round
to actually win the tournament and in
that same game jeffrey had the white
pieces and nakamura had the black pieces
and nakamura was able
to come out with the victory in this
tournament jeffrey's having a
better game and while we talked a lot
about wesley
so and how he sits atop of the
leaderboard jeffrey is half a point
behind him jeffrey's undefeated he has
four wins
and two draws now wesley so coming into
day three has
five wins in one draw but jeffrey has a
lot going for him and looking to get
some revenge on nakamura so let's go
ahead and get started jeffrey
begins with e4 always fun to see
that from the competitors g6
d4 and then we get into the perk defense
here with d6
knight to f3 knight f6 and then knight
c3 so getting into the two knights
variation the classical system against
the perk defense bishop to g7 so if he
encountering that bishop to the king
side
bishop to e3 which usually lends towards
the queen coming to d2
if white wants to castle on the queen
side has that option
pawn d6 c6 excuse me queen to d2
and then pawn b5 so you know may give a
slight pause to white castling
queen side already just because there's
so much pressure coming on the queen
side from these pawns from nakamura
uh so we do see jeffrey play bishop to
d3 just give him some options he can now
castle on
the king side if he wants to
now nakamura continues with knight to d7
just getting more material involved into
the game
knight's blocked here on a c6 so not
coming to the most natural square that
you see
the knights but this also defends the
knight here on f6
and this variation you're usually going
to see the bishop coming here to b7
trying to control these light squares in
the center of the board
we see h3 just stopping this knight
coming down to
g4 at some point which can be
troublesome starting to attack
the white's king side now a5 we do see
some exchange in the center of the board
and then after a four this lets us know
jeffy's probably not going to be
castling on the queen side anymore
starting to chip away at
the queen side structure that nakamura
has
nakamara not looking to trade instead
push forwards
with b4 attacking the knight and usually
once a side pushes the pawns past this
halfway point
they usually want to solidify that pawn
chain because
it is a little more extended than they
may like so that's exactly what we see
we see a5 solidifying that pawn chain
and after c3
knock more doubles down here with c5 now
the bishop here on e3
is attacking the pawn and the knight
here on d7
is defending that so always good to
understand
what pieces and material you are
attacking and what material your
opponent
is defending that with so if you're
looking for moves like deflection moves
or you're looking for forking moves or
pinning down material things like that
are always good
because let's say that white wanted to
pin down this knight
that would then make it very difficult
for the knight to then hold on to this
pawn here on
c5 so those are the things that you
should be looking at in your own game
so we see jeffrey castle on the king
side and then nakamura castles
as well now since both sides have really
developed all their material yes the
bishop here on c8 has not moved yet but
for the most part
both sides are kind of locked in and
this is all known theory so far
so you may hear terms like book move
both of these players are familiar with
this position
and now we start to get into some
novelty as far as how jeffrey wants to
play this game based on his preparation
so
these players not taking a lot of time
getting to
this spot and so as you advance in chess
learning the openings where you're not
spending a ton of time on that
is a huge focus that you should have but
as far as some of the moves
one move that i really like is bishop to
b4 so
you have the bishops in the center
they're not doing too much right now
we've already talked about the knight
here on d7
is defending the pawn on c5 which is
attacked by the bishop here on
e3 so i always like to attack pieces
that are defending
other pieces on the board this is a
great outpost for this bishop and also
it baits this knight here on f6
from coming here to e4 because as we
just mentioned
always looking at what material is
defending other material this
bishop here on d3 is defending the pawn
here on e4 as soon as
that bishop moves to b5 it's no longer
defending that
and it almost looks like a mistake but
knight two e4
capturing that pawn would be a blunder
because now the queen can come up here
to d5
it's not only attacking the knight here
on e4
but it's attacking the rook here on a8
and there's just no real good options uh
that black has
to to stop this they're definitely going
to go down
in material so that's not going to work
this is going to be much better than you
know bishop to
c4 and you can see why because the
bishop's no longer protected by that
pawn that's why the outpost even though
the pawns here on a4
is extremely valuable because now that i
can take here on e4
and even if the queen comes up to d5
it's just not going to go as well
because now knight to b6 whereas before
the queen could just come back here and
take on on e4 and that's all fine and
well but now after he does that
then the bishop could fall here on c4
there could be some in-between moves
bishop to
f5 queen comes over here to h4 they can
even exchange material off but
eventually this bishop here on c4 is
going to fall
previous example with the bishop here on
b5 it's not going to happen so that's
just one example of
how these players are studying these
positions
even before the tournament is going
on other things you could see would be
maybe rook
to d1 always want to get your rooks in
the center of the board
and if there's a semi-open file or an
open file that's a good spot to have it
you could just take here on a b4 makes a
lot of sense pawn takes
opening up for the rook to attack here
on a4 so i'd probably just secure that
with
b3 i think that makes sense
one thing that you don't want to be
doing is something like bishop to
g5 i'd still want to keep pressure on
this c5 square this is not going to work
out as well because
this is a nice little deflection so yes
this knight is being pinned down right
here
uh but after the bishop takes here uh
then all of a sudden the knight can take
here on e4 and yes the knight was pinned
down
but now the knight's attacking the queen
here as well
as the bishop here on g5 so none of
those
are going to work out well on on g5 so
it's definitely not what jeffrey's
looking to do
the other option which he chose in the
game is
knight to g3
nakamura responds with bishop to b7
putting another attacker on this e4
square but that's exactly what the
knight here on
g3 is also defending rook over here to
d1 as we talked about want to centralize
your rooks here
queen two e7 rook here to c1 rook over
here to c1 as well i had a couple
options as far as
where nakamura wanted to bring the rooks
we do start to see some of the pawns
come
off the board here and then bishop to
c4 and this is pinning down this pawn
here on f7
to the king and while that threat right
now
is not the strongest once the material
starts coming off the board this
bishop can be a real problem for black
to deal with
knight to f8 and many times if you've
been watching this channel for
a lot of years we've been doing this for
maybe 11 years now which is kind of
crazy to think about but
as i've analyzed so many of these games
you always recognize that
when players retreat like this they
bring their knights back here to the
eighth rank
they're usually trying to set up some
additional maneuvers
and the good players always strike and
that's exactly what jeffrey does in this
position
he knows that he needs to be aggressive
because nakamura is on his back
foot so he plays queen 2 d6 and after
the exchange he has a rook all up in his
opponent's
position rook to c7 just trying to
eye down this f7 square which is under
attack
and then rook to b6
now part of the reason for rook to b6
is let's analyze this position right
here because there's no reason to play
queen up here to d6 exchange queens
unless you have a very
strong idea in mind but you could be
looking at and say well why don't you
just play
knight takes here on e5 because this
sets up the knight and the bishop both
attacking the pawn here on f7 although
it is protected by
the rook here on c7 but that
leaves this pawn here on e4 under attack
now you could still come up here take on
f7
the rook could take the bishop here on
c4
there could be some exchanges going on
but at the end of the day this is
not going to be extremely beneficial for
white jeffrey kind of runs out of ideas
at this
at this spot and now nakamura has the
bishop pair definitely not what you want
for nakamura to have going into the in
game
with an open board state so instead
jeffrey first plays rook to b6 which
gets the rook out of harm's way if the
knight comes here to e4
because then that knight would no longer
be attacking the rook
the rook is now attacking his bishop
here on b7
still has all the other threats that he
has and then
rook to e8 now this is defending
this pawn here on e5 but jeffrey has
another way to attack this and that's
with knight to
g5 not worried about this pawn anymore
he's looking for the attack
not the material here so still has the
knight and the bishop still eyeing down
on this f7 square you can see the knight
here on f8 has never been able to move
and actually get into the action while
jeffrey has just been able to
chip away and get a better position
bishop comes back here
to a8 rook over here to a6
attacking both the bishop and the pawn
here on a5
bishop to b7 rook takes on a5
jeffrey chipping away here uh gobbling
up some material here
bishop to a you can tell nakamura is not
really doing too much as far as
improving his position just kind of
moving his bishop back and forth losing
some material
while jeffrey continues to get the
position he wants bishop comes back here
to b3
this bishop is nicely placed this rook
here is defending the pawn here on f7 so
he says hey if you want to go and
exchange material here
that's fine i'm up in material so it's
always a good thing to exchange down
if you have an advantage but also to get
that rook off the seventh rank
that would also be a good thing for
jeffrey nakamura is not having it
correctly and plays rook 2 d7
rook 2 a6 from jeffrey pawn to
h6 attacking this knights
but then the knight takes here on f7 and
a huge huge opportunity for jeffrey to
be extremely aggressive bishop
takes here on f7 the king takes and then
rook to
c7 and you can start to see that jeffrey
has
a massive attack coming and it's very
difficult for nakamura to hold on to
this
you can still see that knight here on f8
jeffrey has never
let black get back into this game king 2
g8 rook over here to a7
attacking the bishop
now black takes the pawn here on e4
trying to get something back but it's
just too late
the rook takes here on f6 takes the
knight here
uh saying that yeah you can go ahead and
take my rook which nakamura almost has
to do
but then he loses the bishop here on e4
attacking the bishop
the bishop comes back here to d8 and
then rook to a8
is the final move not in the game but as
far as giving up all
hope uh for nakamura to do anything
because
how does he really move any of this
material here
he can't move his bishop because as soon
as he does his rook is going to fall
if he moves his rook well then the
bishop is going to fall
and what i find ironic is that the last
piece moved in the game before
resignation
is the knight to e6 i feel like black
was almost thinking like hey
you had me stick with my knight there on
f8
and i'm about to resign because nakamura
did resign after this one movie he's
like before i resign
i want to move that night because i'm
not going to let you
just have me keep my knight here on f8 i
got to get i got to move it so
after this he does resign because
there's no way to stop the move that he
knows is coming
and that is knight to f6 this is a
deflection
if the bishop takes here on f6 you can
see
the rook is going to fall very easy in
game
for jeffrey if doesn't take maybe king
to f7
in that case the knight takes here on e8
king takes that's fine bishop takes here
on h6 gobbles up material
pretty easy in game for jeffrey so
what a game by jeffrey uh gets the
victory
in round number seven to start off
day three having a fantastic tournament
uh and to get that against nakamura the
defending champion
i mean he's a teenager going against the
very best one of the best players in the
world but definitely
the reigning champion has got to feel
really really good so congratulations to
him thank you guys so much for watching
this video hopefully you enjoyed it
maybe you even learned something
hopefully you did but thanks so much
and i'll see you guys tomorrow for the
final day
of the us chess championship